okay sixty-six players war zone Kings
here we go I did something dangerous
right there tried to slow my mouse down
let's see if I could adjust to it maybe
it was one speed too high whoa actually
I get used to it um Queen f3 they're
gonna do Queen f3 I just get me whoa did
I fall for a trap no I didn't I could do
this up upon but uh still a bit awkward
here oh this is scary I might have to
now have this covered just in time you
gotta give that pawn up on this check
what does that even do I don't even know
not a good start
let's defend this pawn maybe push them a
little bit my Queen should probably get
out of there maybe get my Knight to f4
this didn't help really get that out of
there
pawn push Knight f4 maybe it wasn't a
good idea to do that maybe not a good
idea
support this pawn push pawn push again
nope Oh Oh what's happening here what is
happening I have enough coverage for
that that's a cool combo that is a cool
combo right there I think they missed
played that I think you're supposed to
take here first or something and then go
with that move it was a move to early
that one was a move to early right there
they're down on time Wow did that take
forever
that would took forever John okay let's
go with this French ah stopped right in
their tracks that you Goren yes they
were fearing the chigorin 6/f ears that
you Goren right there okay all right
they were definitely fearing Queenie -
I've never seen that where's the
resigned but and they said I've never
seen that one before
come here resign button give me that
beep on pigs an early Pig pac-man mode
engaged
I do run the risk of getting trapped
though it's a delicate situation I also
am very behind on development
delicate situation get out of there
Knight would you please get out of there
get out of there night this is dangerous
dangerous territory right here probably
night here one day let's castle first
it's nice and cozy over here pound push
no pin that Bishop pin um actually he's
not pinned Knights guarding but now
they're on their heels their heels whoa
I can't be right watch out for back rank
mates there's no back rank Bates - keep
going upon your past and you are fast
watch out for the fast and past puns
very dangerous flight square flight
squared time get rid of the Queen get
out of there so I could push she didn't
run check let's go clean another clean
mate threat me in where's the quick mate
right here no matter what
back to tournament 12
12 12 11 6 I need I need like a big lead
somehow I need to get a big lead no no
no no okay I have a knight is a juicy
center it's a juicy center everybody
loves this kind of a center don't think
okay stay focused now quit your talking
play chess would you alright let's
preserve your dark square Bishop there
you go tricky stuff against the knight
now take that oh that's a blunder on my
part
yepper very nice very nice
oh man okay well we're gonna have this
aren't we yes we are more trades
happening can I get this pine to be
annoying some how can he be annoying
please not here pawn push first oh man
get that night out of there oh man that
was sad to do that I got that night oh
man scary I don't know what to do I am
in big trouble really big trouble oh man
really big trouble I got to do this I
think or something oh this is falling
apart fast very fast no that'll lead to
me I got a run over here that's a sad
thing to have to do let me tell you
hahaha this is so sad a beat I'm way be
man away be them way be I'm way be oh
definitely be oh man look at my ha ha ha
Wow forget about being checkmated oh I
just got hit with the clock
oh man I never stood a chance
oh now I'm getting hit with the win
gambit oh man
nobody wants to see the wing gambit not
after that man he didn't give me a
second to breathe way legs slow down man
come on why are you going so fast slow
down don't you ever play so fast like
that again come on give me the G file
would you please
okay come on I have a plan the plan is
to give up my night right here it's
juicy I'm gonna deal with that fork it's
okay
it better be okay come on take my night
he's juicy he's definitely very tasty
you know you want him come on the Queen
wants to be on the scene the queen is
gonna be on the scene making one threat
trickiness everywhere trickiness come on
you can do it you can do it you can do
it fight back don't let that one last
detract you okay okay let's roll here
let's go double those points oh I feel
like I don't know what I feel like this
this mouse that's all it is fault its
fault okay here we go oh man what will
happen in that game that I lost
I dropped a piece that'll do it now
oftentimes do the trick
can't be dropping to pieces gotta hang
on to those pieces okay let's get that
let's do this first
let's get these dark square Bishop out
of here actually you know what this
night needs to do whoa the queen is dead
I was gonna I was gonna say the knight
needs to go somewhere else you can
resign sandy beam sandy come on sandy
sandy are you here sandy power of
suggestion you know you want to resign
is it working they don't want to resign
power suggestion is not working you
should really resign right now you
should really resign right now
design-time sandy wants to resign
come on sandy sandy don't let me down
here don't let me Oh mm 20 seconds this
is agonizing right here and meanwhile
I'm drifting back ninth place now they
move when I'm not looking
talk about a sneak attack if I've ever
seen one there
they're moving only when I'm not looking
haha what a tactic they'll never suspect
me move in now right now okay this game
is not gonna end right here right here
that's even better right here is better
push up on right here no matter what
back to tournament they're down 34 wow
I'm still I actually have a fighting
chance a lot of time left here a lot of
time got Wolfman up there at 34 got a
lot of strong horses right there in the
mix who's gonna win the race who's gonna
place your bets place your bets
ah could I really give up that pun let's
hang on to him um what am i doing what
does he really think he has a future
right here he's staring at a rock oh
yeah what a life what a life he's living
yeah stare at the back of a knight right
there that is great that is great okay
over here is where you belong
this is where you know how to be a pest
pawn push let's go break it open get rid
of that double pun breakdown what what
do I want to break down D for D for whoa
that can't be right
chop chop chop chop and then a checker
ooh ski to finish it off
whoa let's go like this maybe just pawn
push we work with that
try something sneaky sneaky sneaky nests
on push the bishop is running scared I
got a bishop that can't be right can it
Bishop is clearly out of squares now has
to go here maybe get out of there Bishop
all right let's try it there Scott there
had to have been something better okay
this is with check and now I got the
bishop more checks around the corner
discovered checks I might have to do
this pig the other pig around the corner
sneaky a sneaky Pig right here pigs no
matter what check no back to term afix
56 42 40 40 alrighty
whoa drifting back hit him little bird
the bird is the word here all right good
night kind of challenge even though this
is my good Bishop I think in order to
make progress I need to get rid of them
oh all right let's take you I don't want
to have to babysit upon there I get this
in here otherwise the bishop would be
dead
I can't castle so easily that's sad sad
news right there I want to get him be
for keep that Bishop after the diagonal
all right yeah only an accident now it's
trapped no it's a trapped bishop I have
absolutely zero confidence in converting
one positions my number-one priority is
just to make sure I'm okay on the clock
and that is not always an easy thing to
do at all okay let's just trade a little
bit can we
can we just trade nice and easy here
hang on oh that would have been bad
because of there have been like a queen
check hang on let's just do this give me
that night I got him
Bishop air whoa I didn't mean to do that
challenge the C file as soon as possible
are they gonna move they're not moving
less than ten okay all right okay let's
go fifty 46664 56 56 54 16 we're not
even halfway there
ah c5 can I get a quick kill
are there any quick kills happening one
day not long ago there were fishing
poles happening quite frequently and now
they have all been sniffed out telling a
story all right I am definitely telling
a story one day well not long ago there
was a little fish and there was a little
no there was a worm this is the worm and
there was a little fish that bites at
the worm come on
ah man that's not happening can I still
get this somehow move Knight can I force
it can I make it happen
not what I wanted to see um
so much for my little fishing pool
that's the anti fishing pole I want to
get an H no they're not having any of it
I have it protected on my night he likes
this square
I think this pond push is good yeah
watch out for this though my night is in
a great spot it's open this up I'm not
sure why let's come over here my this
was the only way I could get my rook
into play I think walk a little
tightrope here with my King have my rook
come to d8 and then my rook on a could
play there down on time this game isn't
gonna finish where is it okay now maybe
I could push up here oh yeah no no no no
let's get out of pins they were being
tricky over here's where you belong
grab this pawn target the b-pawn now
he's dead dead pond
uh-oh moving fast tricky checks and I
just dropped my rock it doesn't matter
okay they're down on time ninety ninety
eighty four eighty seventy two seventy
two I'm struggling for victory lane here
top three can we get to top three here
I'm gonna sack that pond go for this
variation and they just take that pond
would you with your pond okay let's try
to make my LightScribe bishop work
somehow I make him work my Queen out and
about come on Queen be contributor
contribute
darn it it backfired on age six if they
Castle let's go my bishop is tough to
get out okay I'm on aged six something
feels good
something feels really good over here
where are the tricks it just feels right
I don't know and this feels right to
take take your pick eenie meenie miney
moe if you have to okay come on be a
thorn you know you want to be a thorn be
a thorn he's a thorn he's a thorn I have
just enough gas just enough gas me back
to tournament 90 88 no double-check that
one 110 oh man just can't be easy I
can't have a lead can I
there's no cushions absolutely no
cushions here
cushion cushions okay watch out for the
very deadly okay that's a pun a very
deadly pun okay so let's back up maybe
hit him with a quick me 9 f3 is
happening not gonna fall for that trick
the bishops gonna kill something it's
back up let's go Knight contribute let's
go LightSquared Bishop take tonight I'm
still gonna take them mate threads make
it 1 2 3 or something it's not so clear
not so clear I have to watch out for
this pawn defend out my rook instead of
push if I push there's Queen here that
can't be right can it let's give a check
first I'll go check where's the mate
make it - yes yes yes come on just move
yes in the corner mate 110 108 111
minutes and change come on come on you
can do it you could do it you could do
it
let's go F pawn
I'm winning upon here that is officially
a free pun okay whoa what's going on
with that pod capture I got to get
castled here I'm okay with that
let's have the D file open up actually
let's do this
my queen wants to be over here where
there's an isolated pond it's a good
home where there are isolated ponds
there are often good homes for pieces on
the same file as those isolated ponds
two isolated ponds and I'm up to ponds
look up and over let's just do that
connected past pond get my rope doing
something look up and over hang on hang
on hang on let's go Brooke let's go here
hit the bishop he's passed and he's fast
where does my bishop want to be okay
let's trade Queens first my bishop wants
to be hitting f6 let's grab a pawn first
why not he's a good one pawns you in
here let's get out of pins
get out of there rook that was stupid of
me to do why did I do that yes to these
questions
push that pot huh you went there for a
reason he's passed this is terrible
technique it's a good thing I have like
a time edge come on give me that bishop
I got the bishop
I do whoa sneak attack right there this
game is not gonna finish step ladder
step ladder they're down in time back to
chairman one 3128 okay come on you
Roberto
again stakes have been doubled
last time I got it I got that pond
didn't I what happened that last game
let's get this in okay pressure on that
pond actually I'm gonna try this seems
interesting okay pac-man I'm on G to
take that night and get G to still G to
twice G 2/3 times moved upon whoa this
is gonna sting this is gonna be made oh
ho ho this is deadly mate right this is
check and then mate next Oh kitchen sink
don't don't don't don't
okay I thought they're gonna time take
148 I have a lead 148 130 come on give
me a cushion give me a cushion spaz spaz
has something to say about me being in
the lead not so fast
he says Knight f3 my Knights pinned d5
might be there and stop that pin first
maybe I could pin their night Oh triple
pawns don't look over here don't look
over here it's very ugly no it's not
here we go centralize the night right
here the Queen has to run home my knight
wants to go somewhere else this pawn
push is happening let me get my Queen
active stop that pie advance backup
watch out for this break and I'm gonna
do something weird looking maybe okay no
my knight has a good home Knight has a
good home here I have a treat of 3 to 2
majority I need to get these pawns going
here pound push again I could take here
I'll be protecting my Queen if that was
a file take care and Beyond the Queen
okay this is kind of working out
I really don't want to go into that
imbalance I'm on the Queen forks forks
I'm up a rook in a knight now with this
line they resigned back to term at 168
150 I have 14 games in one was the last
though
oh no no oh I gotta go to Cairo I better
try something else
this guy has given me beating after
beating the only thing I could ever do
against this guy's stare at a clock come
on run out of time that's my tactic
against this guy hopefully he just runs
out of time because he will beat me
again and again and again
thank you sir deal atlas he doesn't care
he doesn't have he has no feelings for
me here he'll beat me time and time
again does not matter this is the
Wolfman right here the Wolfman will give
out the beatings no doubt however am I
gonna get a pawn from the wolf is the
wolf gonna go down okay let's go Knight
you know where you belong don't you
right here my queen is here to stay
she's okay ah let me reinforce that
night he's a beautiful piece right there
what's up with that Bishop he's up to no
good
oh you see this is what I mean he could
just never make it easy on me come on
quit putting up so much resistance this
is very scary because I am opposite that
Bishop but uh got a play to win don't
you let's try this
okay they went in a different direction
over here I'm gonna push no I could come
back over okay things are so bad now
take that okay I have the time situation
at the very least time situation okay I
have time just take here didn't have any
time
pac-man down that time back to
tournament Oh 191 88 four minutes and
change I don't have a lead Oh yellow
bear yellow bear let's go here we go all
right space advantage
um Bishop here I'm prepping fishing like
positions
come on Knight f6 this can't be right
can it
I'm getting a piece where's the mate
give a check bishop just blocks I just
helped them develop
Oh why'd I do that why help your
opponent develop don't you dare do that
ever don't help your opponent like that
oh I just dropped a piece oh come on I
just dropped a piece No oh man the
yellow bear the yellow bear has me on
the ropes has me on the ropes he's run
reversed you might be scared though
that's all I can hope for are they
scared hopefully they're scared I got
forks forks forks for its I got a piece
back uh-oh
I got a piece with the fork uh-oh but oh
domino effect tables have turned
tables have turned the yellow bear had
me on the ropes on the ropes I was there
goes upon he's free
that's contesta file another free piece
oh they resigned back determine 208 whoa
come on let's get another one in yellow
bear had me
whoa I'm gonna fear the yellow bear
fear the yellow bear meal train he is
gonna have something to say about me
being in the lead here ah man this is
gonna be very very difficult I should
have done that sooner okay can I um I'm
in trouble here I am in trouble
I need to UM stop that bishop from doing
some damage there Oh need to get rid of
that light-square bishop can I do that
please
LightSquared bishop you need to go is
this gonna work
is this gonna work please please say
it's gonna work
come on lights go bishops get off the
board oh that's an important ingredient
isn't it oh I didn't mean to do that
oh they're trying to be sneaky right
there oh this is dangerous
come on trade queens please my queen is
on the scene okay how do I make sense of
this I gotta remember that get rid of
that pond get rid of that pond bishop
checks is this me
whoa this is deadly discover tricks
everywhere look at the lasers right
there lasers everywhere whoa I'm gonna
take this one I just want to get rid of
that pond right there for sure they
resigned back to tournament 228 I have a
lead come on if that guy wins he's gonna
be up by two points what is this
48 seconds if he wins that's it I need
to get this win if he wins he wins come
on let's go let's go can I get that
pound real quick now they're not gonna
have any of that can I open this up 33
seconds they're gonna take here can I
get the Queen though where's the main
where's the main there's no main here
oh there's definitely not any mate uh I
need a quick mate what does that kind of
move is that
ten seconds hopefully he just didn't win
come on call it come on back up back up
back up Queen here I see a possibility
for a mate right here right here mate
thread or something come on come on come
on come on what is it this mate right
here come on what is it what is it what
is it what is it Oh second place he got
that one in ah man what can you do ah
man 230 ah good tournament good games
off to 32 28 191 198